All right, so this is the
state of the Shiny website
at the time of this recording.
So it might be different by the
time people actually see this.
But if we just start from
this landing page for Shiny
for Python, then you
can click on Examples.
And there's a whole
bunch of examples here.
And you can select
them from the sidebar.
So I'm just going to go down--
Wordle's all the way down
here in this advanced section.
And here's our Wordle app.
What's your Wordle
starting word?
My Wordle starter?
It's arise.
Can we play Wordle?
I haven't played Wordle
since the last [INAUDIBLE]..
Let me make this a
little bit bigger here.
All right.
Are you still playing
Wordle every day?
I am not.
I was really
hardcore for a while.
And then I just stopped
and forgot one day.
And then I forgot the next day.
And I just haven't really done
very much of it since then.
All right, so my
starter is arise.
I'll just type that
on my keyboard.
Did you just hit Enter
to make it do that, too?
Yes, I did.
So yeah, and actually,
I should point out
that that keyboard
interaction, that
is some custom JavaScript
that's added to this app.
Because normally, for
a normal web page,
if you just type it
in, it's not going
to send the key presses
to, necessarily,
where you want to go.
So there's a little bit
of JavaScript, which I'll
walk through that does that.
It's pretty simple.
So what's your strategy?
Do you go, I'm going to keep
A, I, S in my next guess?
Or are you like, nope, I'm
going to go for full coverage.
I'm going to pick something
that excludes those.
Yeah, unless I
think I can get it,
the word, in the
next guess, I usually
use another word that will
cover the rest of the vowels.
So my next word that I
usually use is pouty.
This is amazing.
You have a whole strategy.
[CHUCKLES]
All right, so now I know
there's no other vowels.
And yeah, there's
T, A, I, and S.
And so far, they've all
been in the wrong spot.
And my guess would be
that the S is last.
That's common.
Well, that would
be, if S is last,
it would almost be like
blank, A, I, T, S, which--
Right.
Oh, except for the T and the
I can't be in those locations.
I keep coming up with
words that have the letter
R, which is not helpful.
Yeah.
Stain.
Stain?
S-T-- maybe.
That's pretty good.
That's good.
Hey!
Nice work, Jesse.
[LAUGHING]
Teamwork.
Nice.
That was pretty good-- three.
Awesome.
And then it's got
a nice little--
you've got a little pop-up.
Yeah, you can take this, and
you can copy and paste it
into Twitter and then
just really confuse
the heck out of everyone there.
[LAUGHS] That's great.
Now, didn't you build this
so that you could play in
as many guesses as you wanted?
Yes.
That was-- sometimes
I get a little lazy,
and I just want to guess and not
have to think too hard about it
and worry about failing.
So yeah.
So this one, it doesn't stop.
You can just keep guessing
as many times as you want.
I thought, let's start with
the very minimal thing,
the smallest, simplest
possible thing
that we can build and try to
evolve that into this game
here.
So that started out with just
having a simple text input
and letting people type in
some stuff and hit Enter.
And then from there,
it's like, OK, now,
let's limit that
to five characters.
Let's actually add a
word list so that they're
guessing a particular word.
Let's save all their previous
guesses and then display them.
For the Wordle app,
I could sort of
see a path from this very
simple, let's start with just
text input and let's try to turn
it into this full-fledged game
here.
And that's something
that I guess
you could get from experience.
Like, you can see,
OK, I think it's
possible to get from
point A to point B.
But sometimes you can't just
start with something really,
really simple and evolve it
into something that looks nice
and is sophisticated like this.
So sometimes you do have
to sit-- well, for me,
at least-- sometimes I have to
sit down and just figure out,
what are going to be
the big parts of this,
and how are they
going to fit together?
How much Python did you
know when you were doing
this, when you started this?
So when I started
the Wordle app?
I think I've had--
I've been programming-- spending
most of my time in Python--
well, and also in JavaScript--
for just about the last year
or so.
But before that, I had
barely used Python at all.
So but I think by the time--
when I started this app,
though--
when did I do this?
This was about four
months ago, I think.
I think it was longer.
Was it?
I feel like this
was January/February.
Oh, you might be right.
Yeah, this might have been
one of the first things.
Like, hey, guys,
look what I made.
They were all like, what?
I remember I'd just be--
at least the way
that I remember it,
the story that I'm
telling myself--
is that you were like,
had a couple hours,
thought I'd do something fun.
Now we have Wordle with
Python in the browser,
and you can do
unlimited guesses.
Yeah.
Well, I mean it helped
that there was--
we already did the R one first.
That's true.
So just for context, how long
have you been writing R code?
I'm thinking of
[INAUDIBLE],, just--
Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHS] Doing serious R work?
Probably the last, I would
say, maybe 11 years doing that.
Yeah, so that's a
lot of time to be--
That's a lot of time.
--working in R. So I mean,
there's a lot of nice things
about Python.
I think it's, in terms of
just the language itself,
it's designed to
be easy to learn.
And it encourages sort
of a clean coding style.
There are some
annoying limitations
if you come from a
functional programming
language like R or JavaScript.
It doesn't really support
anonymous functions.
It does if they're one
statement or one expression.
But you can't have a multi-line
anonymous expression,
which means that you end up
creating all these functions
that you have to give names
to before you can pass them
to another function.
And there's some really weird
stuff and difficult stuff
with the tooling for
Python, just not in Python
itself but all the
stuff around Python,
like how to install packages
and use them in a reliable way.
How do you build a package?
There's a zillion
ways to do things.
And that's pretty difficult.
When I was first looking
into becoming a data scientist,
I was going to learn Python.
And it took me forever
to get it installed.
Sometimes I couldn't
get it installed.
But then it was like
pip install, whatever.
And no one told you where
to put the command pip.
And so I would put
it in my browser.
Yeah, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
You run Python,
and it launches
Python 2 on your computer
instead of Python 3.
And then none of the stuff
that you installed with pip
is there.
And it's like, why
isn't that working?
It's a good time.
That stuff is not fun.
But actually, that's
one reason that I'm
really excited about all this
online editing stuff that we've
built. We have this editor
here where you can just
get started running
Shiny, and all the stuff's
already installed.
You don't have to
install Python.
install any packages.
You don't even have to run
this on a normal computer.
You can run this on an iPad,
where you wouldn't even
be able to install
Python, normally.
And you get all
this assistance now.
Like, if I want to start
working in this UI here--
so I can say like
ui.input_checkbox.
And then it's got all
its autocompletion stuff
that's [INAUDIBLE].
This is pretty new, right?
This is new, actually, yeah.
This actually wasn't-- this
didn't exist in the last video
that we recorded.
This was just implemented
in the last couple of weeks.
So yeah, and then you can
hover over it and there's--
it's a little bit finicky--
but it gives you the whole
documentation right here.
So that has been super helpful.
That's really helpful for
coding in the browser.
And it also has that
support for that,
for the Python standard library.
So I can say from
os import path.
And then I can
say path.basename.
And then it gives you all these
hints here to write the code.
So that will hopefully be a big
help for people to get started.
And again, you don't
have to install
all the stuff in your computer
and get that all set up.
You can get that
stuff set up, like,
for example, with VS Code, which
I often use for coding Python.
And it's really, really nice.
But that's more stuff
you have to set up, then.
It's like, OK, you've
got to set up this code.
You've got to install
the Python extensions.
You've got to configure the
Python extensions to give you
the right sort of
assistance and have it not
flag too many things as errors.
So there's a lot of work,
a lot of manual work, that
would be involved if you set
it up on your own system.
But if you don't
want to do that,
you can just come right in here
and get working right away.
I feel like we're cheating.
I feel like--
[LAUGHS]
I feel like there's
a catch, like you're
going to be like, you can
do all these cool things--
there's no free lunch.
I mean, this isn't a theorem
or anything like that.
But if I want to
learn Shiny, this
feels like such an
approachable way to do it.
Yeah.
Eventually, you'll probably,
if you're doing a lot of Shiny,
writing a lot of Shiny
code, eventually, you'll
probably hit some
sort of roadblocks
if you just work this way.
So in developing this editor,
we've tried to remove as many
of those as possible.
So you can save these
files to your disk.
You can load them from disk,
even though this is all
running in your web browser.
But when it comes to
deploying your application,
you're going to have to get
into the command line world
and if you want to do
stuff that you can't
do in this version of Shiny
that's running completely
in the browser with Python
compiled to WebAssembly.
So if you want to fetch
data from a database
and you don't want to share
those credentials with the rest
of the world, or you just want
to work on a data set where you
need a really powerful computer
to do some computation,
this isn't going to
really work for you.
To send the code to the user's
browser for them to execute it,
that might not work.
So then you have to run it
the traditional way, which
is with Python
running on the server.
And you're going to
have to get your hands
dirty with installing
Python and configuring it
and all that sort
of stuff there.
I'm going to say
it's not too bad.
VS Code does it for
me, and it just works.
And so I have not touched it.
That's true.
Visual Studio, too.
Visual Studio did
my C#, my Python.
And it just works.
And I was like you know
what, Visual Studio?
We're just not going
to touch anything else.
This is all in Python,
but you've also mentioned
some CSS and some JavaScript.
Yeah, OK.
Yeah, let's talk about this.
So I'm going to
actually switch over
to another tab where I have
the same thing running locally.
Because I've actually
made some changes.
One of the things
that I talked about
was this JavaScript to
deal with the key presses.
So this keyboard here, these
are all action buttons.
And when you click on
them, it sets a value
that the server
function can read.
So this is, obviously,
that's the button P there.
And I can hit Backspace.
Now, in order to trigger
these with the keyboard,
I had to set up a little
bit of extra stuff.
And it's relatively simple.
at least as this
JavaScript code goes.
So basically, I set
up, in JavaScript,
an array of all these letters.
And then I add an event
listener for a keydown event.
So this is just a JavaScript.
So when the button is pressed,
then it gets the element by ID.
So the elements that--
I created these
buttons with IDs--
A, B, C, D, and so on.
And then it triggers
a click on them.
And then there's special
handling for the Enter and Back
buttons.
But yeah, that's
basically it is I'm
just basically like when
somebody presses the keyboard,
it triggers a click
on the Action button.
And the rest of it is just
sort of normal Shiny behavior.
And if you're not
familiar with JavaScript
but you still want to do
this, it's really easy.
You can just copy
and paste this code.
So if I'm copying
and pasting your code,
am I just putting it
inside tags.script?
Oh, yeah.
Yes, right.
So I have tags.script here.
Actually, let me explain
that a little bit.
So tags is actually
something that I imported
from the htmltools package.
And that is something that has
all of the HTML tag functions,
so like div, span,
script, in this case.
Now, you can do it that way,
import it from your htmltools.
Or another place
that it's available
is also via the UI
object in Shiny.
So I can say ui.tags--
actually, I'm going
to delete all this.
So let's start over.
So I can say ui.tags.,
and then these
are all of the
available HTML tags.
So the one that I want,
though, is script.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] closing parenthesis.
And there we are.
So this would put it in
a script tag in HTML.
And then the browser knows
that it's JavaScript.
That's really cool.
And then it's just all
within your broader UI?
Yep.
So let's just anywhere
in the UI for that app.
You can put it there, and
then the browser will just
execute that JavaScript code.
That's really cool.
Yeah, it's pretty easy
to add the JavaScript.
So when you're adding
it-- so this is all,
looks like it's in a docstring.
But it's still--
Yeah.
Well, it's not
exactly a docstring.
It's a triple-quote
string, actually.
You know what?
I could be getting my
terminology wrong for Python.
So for docstrings, you usually
write them with triple quotes.
But it just means that
with the triple quotes,
I can use multiple lines.
This string can
span multiple lines.
But it's like--
this would be a traditional way
of commenting something out.
But you're saying because
it's in the triple quotes,
it's still reading
this JavaScript.
Yeah.
Well, it's-- well, because
it's in the triple codes,
it treats it just as a string.
But I can still use--
the string can span
multiple lines.
And I can use quotes
in it without making
it confused that it's
the end of the string,
unless I put three in a row.
To Shiny, this is just text.
And I happen to be sticking
it in the script tag.
And so then--
actually, if I do--
I wonder if I can do it in here.
Yeah, so then Shiny
is just like, OK,
I'm going to just put the
string in a script tag.
And that's going to be in the
web page like here, right here.
Now, there's actually a file
in this app called style.CSS.
And what I'm doing
here is I'm actually
just reading in this file's
text and returning it.
And then it's sticking it
in the app as a string.
So this is the styling, this
CSS stuff, for this Wordle app.
And in this case, instead
of putting it in line
like I did with the JavaScript,
I read it in from the file.
So that's another way of doing
something that's similar.
And actually, the
nice thing about that,
then, is that this
editor understands CSS.
And so it gives me some
syntax highlighting.
And I think it'll tell
me if they've got--
well, maybe not.
I thought it would tell me if
there was problems with it.
But it apparently does not.
But it does have
syntax highlighting.
And if you use
another editor, it
might be smart enough to
give you that sort of help.
So I could have put
the JavaScript code
in the same way.
So create a new file
with the JavaScript
and then just insert
it similar to this.
There's multiple
files in this app.
And one of them was a CSS file.
Another one is
this words.py file.
So all the words are
defined in this Python file.
And you can just import
that the way you normally
would from in a Python script.
So you'd say import words.
And also, once again, most
of these htmltools objects
are actually available
via UI, via the Shiny UI.
So the Shiny.UI module
actually imports htmltools,
and then it exports
most tools things.
So I think, actually,
for this, I technically
didn't have to import them
from htmltools directly.
Some of this JavaScript
code here, like this stuff
here, this was all
touch interaction,
like on your phone or iPad.
Because that's often
how I play Wordle.
And with the normal Wordle app--
or the real Wordle
app, I should say--
I find it a little annoying.
You touch the letter,
and it doesn't
register until you
let go, you raise
your finger off the letter.
Still, that lag
kind of bothers me.
And so I added these
other event listeners
so that when you
touch the letter,
it immediately registers it.
So you don't have to
touch and then release.
So that's what this
stuff does here.
I'm really impatient for
this UI interaction stuff.
I love this is--
I don't want to say it's
spite-driven development,
but it's like this little thing
that you know how to improve.
So you make your
own version of it.
I love it.
So here's another thing
that's unusual about this app
that we haven't done in
any of the other examples.
And it's to create, actually,
a subclass of inputs
where we specify the type
of these various inputs.
So this is what Shiny knows,
like hey, when somebody presses
the Enter button,
what kind of value
is going to come out of that?
So we say class ShinyInputs.
And this makes it a
subclass of inputs.
And just declare
all these things
here-- the Enter button
and the Back button.
Those return integer values,
as does the New_game button.
And so that's so
you know, hey, this
doesn't return a
string or a Boolean.
It returns a number.
So inside of the server
app, first I just
say, hey, take the input object
and cast it to ShinyInputs.
Just treat it as ShinyInputs.
Then I can say--
oops-- I can say
@output, @render.text,
and def my function here--
oh, wait, no I
need to [INAUDIBLE]
and call it def txt.
And if I say return
input.Enter, it's
going to say, hey, there's
something wrong here.
This error message is
kind of long and cryptic.
But the important part
is Function return type
"int" is incompatible with
Available string or None.
So it's complaining about this.
This returns a number,
but this render text
wants a function that
returns a string.
What I would have to do is
convert that to a string.
Now, it turns out that
if you handle the number
to render text, it'll try to
convert it to a string, anyway.
But there's other
weird objects that you
might give to it that
have the wrong shape.
Like if you return
a dictionary to it
or if you return to some sort of
arbitrary weird Python object,
it might not know
how to handle it.
So having these-- declaring
the types of these inputs
and having it check
them is really helpful.
Well, if you are really strict
about things, so if I say,
hey, I've got X, and
X is a dictionary of--
or sorry, it's a
list of strings,
I can't say, assign this Boolean
value to that list of strings--
well, for two reasons.
One is that it's Boolean.
The other one is
that it's not a list.
So it's not a list,
and it's not a string.
But maybe I said, hey,
X is a list of strings.
I'll assign it this
empty brackets first.
And then I can say
x.append(input.hard).
So it's like, hey, no.
This is a Boolean.
This is not a string.
You've still got an error.
So then I can say,
oh, you know what?
That's right.
I actually need to convert
this to a string first.
Or maybe I want to say, hey,
yes, if it's input.hard else
"no."
So this expression is going
to return to either yes or no,
depending on the
value of input.hard.
So having these
types can help you
avoid bugs in your
code in combination
with a smart editor
like this that
will flag these type errors.
Yeah, actually, one thing
that I wanted to talk about
was this use of reactive
values here, reactive.value.
So there is a bunch
of these here.
One of them is the target word.
One of them is
all of the guesses
that the user has
made in this round,
whether the game has ended, and
what are the current guess--
the current letters
in the guess.
So if I type A, R,
I, those letters
are the letters in
the current guess.
You don't see this for
really basic Shiny apps.
You don't see this
reactive.value stuff.
Let me pull up s really
simple example here.
So let's go to this
basic app here.
So this basic app, you
just have an input--
input.n, and then that
gets used by this output.
So for an app like this, if
I set the state of an input,
that will be consumed
by the output.
And that's that.
And so there's no
recording of history.
Like what was the previous
state of an input, that just
isn't part of this application.
That's just totally--
it's just totally gone.
And that's what
happens if you just
have inputs just that are
used by outputs but nothing
to record the previous states.
So here, I'm using reactive
values to record the history.
So the history,
in this case, was
that I pressed A, R, I. And
then I can fill it out, S, E.
And if I hit Enter,
then arise will
be recorded in all_guesses.
So when you see these
reactive values,
that's often what it's
used for is to help
record some previous state.
And that's important for
many more sophisticated
applications.
All right, so another unusual
feature about this app
is, so I'm creating
reactive effects that
respond to each key press.
But I'm doing that in a loop.
So that is a little bit unusual.
So let's see here.
So I created a list
called Keys that's--
where is it?
It's up here.
So this is all the letters in
the keyboard, or all the ones
that we want to use.
And so I had all these
action buttons here, right?
This one is named Q, W, E, R.
Those are all individual action
buttons.
And I want this application
to update the current guess
letters whenever one of
those buttons is pressed.
Now, one way to do that is I
could create a reactive effect
for every single one.
So I could do-- oops,
let's not put it there.
I'll put it down here.
I could say-- sorry--
reactive.Effect, reactive.event,
and this would listen
to input.Q--
I think it's capitalized.
And then I'd say def_.
And then in here, I'd say, OK,
when the Q button is pressed,
take the
current_guess_letters and--
or actually, this is a
little bit complicated.
current_guess_letters.
And go get its
function, copy it.
I'll just call this x--
x.append("q") and then
current_guess_letters.set(x).
So there's actually a
few things going on here.
This is actually an
important enough digression
that I'm going to
do it right now.
current_guess_letters,
it will return a list.
And you see that I'm copying
this list, modifying it,
and then setting
current_guess_letters
to that new list, instead
of just taking that list
and modifying it.
So the reason for
that is because this
is a reactive value.
And in order for it
to inform everyone
that consumes-- all
of the things that
use that reactive value,
they need to know,
hey, the value here has
changed in order for them
to invalidate and to know
that they have to recompute.
Now, if I were to just take
this and then append q to it
and not do this copying
and setting stuff,
then I would modify
that list, but I
wouldn't be informing everyone
that it had been updated.
And also, it could confuse
some other code, if I just
modify that object in place.
So that's actually one important
difference between Python
and R is that, in R, most
objects are immutable.
And so you actually can't
cause this sort of problem.
But in Python, you
have to be aware
of what objects can
be changed in place
and how that can cause problems
with this reactive computation.
Now, I don't think that Shiny
is unique in this respect.
I know if you're working
with Pandas data frames,
the same thing can also happen.
But it is one more thing
to be aware of compared
to the R version of Shiny.
We would have to do
this for every single key
on our keyboard.
Right.
So I did this for the
letter Q. I did it
for the letter W and
E, R, T, all of those.
But obviously,
that's really tedious
and will take up
a bunch of space.
And then if I found out that
there was a bug in my code,
I'd have to change all of
them, which is a huge pain.
So instead of doing it this way,
what I did was I created a--
so there's a function
make_key_listener
which creates this
reactive effect that
listens for a specific key.
So it can take the
name of the key.
So the first one would be Q.
And it's a reactive event.
It's listening for input[key].
This is actually equivalent to--
I can do input.Q here,
or I can do input ["Q"]..
Those actually both work.
Those are equivalent.
The dot syntax is a
little bit more convenient
if you're just typing it
out for a single thing.
But if you need to
programmatically access
an input value, you can do
it this way, in the bracket.
So I'm saying,
listen for whatever
key I was told to listen to,
and then do all that same stuff
that we just saw,
except the key here
is, instead of hard coding Q,
it comes in from this function
call.
So if I call this function,
I can pass it the letter Q
and the letter W
and E and so on.
And that's what I'm doing here.
I have a for loop that creates
the key listener for all
of those keys.
And again, there's exceptions
for entering backbones
because those are
handled separately.
Those have different
behavior from the other keys.
But essentially, it just
it calls this in a loop.
Now, you might be
thinking, hey, can I just,
instead of making
this function here,
can I just copy this code and
just stick it right down here?
If I could say, hey, forget
putting it on this function.
I'll just put it right there
and properly indent it.
So if you do this, though,
it's not going to work.
The problem is that--
it has to do with how it
captures the value of key.
Actually, I'll just
put it here first so
that we can take a look.
So what this is
going to do, it's
going to iterate over
all of the keys, where
I've got this inner for loop.
This variable key
will change every time
it goes through the loop.
What ends up happening is it
does create a separate reactive
effect for each
one of those keys.
But this value of key is
shared across all of them.
And it actually keeps changing.
So maybe it's best if
I just demonstrate.
So let me just
run this app here.
So I've changed it so instead of
calling this make_key_listener
function, it's actually creating
those effects in this loop
here.
And if I press the button A--
I hope this is actually
going to work--
it did something crazy.
Wow, that is not
what I expected.
Oh, I did.
OK, this is actually
the same problem.
Wait, this is actually the
problem I was talking about.
It just ended up somewhere
where I didn't expect.
So here's-- let's see-- all
the letters are up here.
So it just iterates
over them in this order.
So it goes from Q, W,
da-da-da-da-da, all the way.
And then the last one is Back.
So the value of key
actually kept changing
as it iterated over this.
And the scope for
this variable, it's
scoped to the server
function, this key variable.
It's not saving the value
of key for each time
we call this loop.
This variable key
here is actually
at the top level of
the server function.
And it kept changing as we
were going through the loop.
When we called it in
this function here,
instead of that key constantly
changing-- actually,
I can just rename this to
something a little bit--
I'll just call this
k to make it clearer.
This letter k here,
this variable k,
is just scoped
within this function.
So when I was saying, hey, make
a key_listener(key) and then--
ignore that stuff down there--
it passed in the
letter Q. And then
it created this reactive
effect and reactive event.
And the variable k
had the value of q.
And that was captured within
the scope of this closure.
That's the terminology.
And then they created a separate
one, a separate closure scope,
for W and for E. And
so that variable k
is not shared across
all of those instances.
So that's what happened
here, as opposed to we
had in this messed-up version,
where the variable value of key
was shared across all
of them, and so it
did something really bizarre.
So I hope that made sense.
As soon as you said closure,
I was like, I hear Jenny.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, great.
[LAUGHS] Let Jenny
be your guide.
Yeah, always, literally.
Yeah, so that's most
of the weird stuff that
is in this application.
There is some CSS.
I won't get too into
depth about that.
That's a whole-- that's nothing
specific to Shiny about this.
This is just web
development stuff, which--
I'm also OK with CSS.
I'm not great with CSS.
I wouldn't be the
person to explain it.
And a lot of the
CSS to lay this out
was just sort of trial and
error and me hacking away at it
until I got something
that looked decent.
I feel like--
not a CSS person myself-- but I
feel like that's the right way
to do it.
In sort of the
tree of complexity
for your application, this
is just sort of a leaf node.
It's just, OK, just
make this work.
It's not going to
mess up anything else.
All right, so yeah.
That's Wordle.
[WHOOSH]